I'd more rather know about the last page
you wrote In The Script I never put it
down man I don't I never put it down I'm
constantly like retooling stuff I miss
you
so much well what I'm trying to say
Peter you know this is an open line
right not in a big way because I've had
the basic script for years that's a
pretty name Lila
thank you but you know I'm always
rewriting stuff I'm always writing down
new lines that I throw the cast while
we're shooting
just constantly throwing them new lines
push down on it what because I have
stuff in my mind that I like it looks
like you're pushing the keyhole and I
know it's going to be better if I just
throw it to them and they say it as
opposed to them reading it and
rehearsing it there's a button under the
handle
press that in so yeah I'm always I'm
always writing now what open the door